ja wir haben das thema ja schon
angeschnitten ich muss mal mich wieder
sammeln weil das bedrückt mich wirklich
was ich hier jetzt beobachte und zwar
schon seit wochen wie nämlich mit den
ungeimpften umgegangen wird ich bin
selbst drei mal geimpft und wenn es eine
vertiefung der elbe würde ich mir die
aufholen wenn sie mir hilft da bin ich
ganz entschieden und das kann ich auch
nur jedem raten aber wenn wir beobachten
was wir in welcher form die ungeimpften
die ja täglich getestet werden damit sie
überhaupt arbeiten können 3g und in
öffnen verkehrsmitteln fahren können
dass die aus dem restlichen leben
ausgeschlossen werden auch wenn sie
getestet sind und zwar negativ getestet
das ist völlig unmöglich - und zwar vor
augen führen was das in dieser zeit
bedeutet die dürfen etwa ein restaurant
gehen dürfen kein café gehen die dürften
kein konzert besuchen in der
vorweihnachtszeit sie dürfen nicht ins
theater gehen sie dürfen mit ihren
kindern nicht ins kino gehen um
weihnachtsfilm zu sehen sie können noch
nicht mal in einem spielzeuggeschäft
gehen um ihren kindern ein
weihnachtsgeschenk zu kaufen und am
heiligabend
dürfen nicht in die kirche was sind denn
das für verhältnisse ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich finde dass erbarmungslos und
schäbig diesen menschen gegenüber sie
haben sich nichts zu schulden kommen
lassen sie sind sie haben verstoßen
nicht gegen gesetze sie nehmen die
freiheit die sie haben in anspruch und
in lausanne hätte niemals gedacht dass
dieses land so schäbig mit einer
bedeutenden minderheit umgeht ich nenne
das
corona apartheid ich weiß zwar dass das
ein zugespitzter begriff ist aber so
empfinde ich das und denjenigen die sich
ständig darüber beklagen dass das land
gespalten wird tun selbst das
allermeiste dafür das land zu spalten
indem sie diesen teil der bevölkerung
nämlich pauschal ausgrenzen als
angebliche rechtsextremisten
verschwörungstheoretiker spinnt die sera
und so weiter das ist natürlich ein
dramatisches fehlurteil in unserem
grundgesetz heißt es alle menschen sind
vor dem gesetz gleich es heißt nicht
alle geimpft
sind vor dem gesetz gleich ich kann dir
da nur komplett zustimmen ich muss auch
wirklich sagen es gibt ja noch viel
schlimmere fälle also letztes mal spiel
in düsseldorf war ein mann der hat sich
nicht impfen lassen ich finde das wort
ungeimpfte ja schon wirklich nicht mehr
menschlich das sollte mir eigentlich gar
nicht bloß der hat sich gegen die
impfung entschieden ist mit seinem
kleinen sohn darum gelaufen wollte den
mandeln kaufen an einem stand im freien
wurde gesagt darf er nicht weiß ist
zweig das muss man sich mal überlegen
das hat nichts mehr übrigens mit dem
kampf gegen das infektionsgeschehen zu
tun weil in diese in dieser lage mit f2
maske draußen um kurzen wandel zu holen
und das schlimm es hat mir auch schon am
montag ist es wert wird jetzt auch schon
menschen der arbeitsplatz in manchen
fällen genommen und der studienplatz
also viele zu studenten bank jetzt schon
ob sie ab märz nächstes jahre studieren
können uns hat ja ein leser aus dem fach
zahnmedizin geschrieben ein zuschauer
und ich muss sagen ich sehe das ganz
genauso wie du und ich fand es gar nicht
überspitzt ich empfinde das auch so und
ich habe angst um den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt spanische
kulturminister ein cdu mann hat ja
angedroht dass man zweig am arbeitsplatz
anwenden will was meint er damit sagen
manche aus dir ungeimpften ihren job
verlieren werden reicher bezahlt müssen
zu hause ist das denn es hat der
diskussion darüber begonnen dass
ungeimpfte auch nicht mehr im supermarkt
einkaufen dürfen das hat die
supermarktkette j lo für sich
entschieden dass sie das nicht tun
werden also ich finde es eigentlich
vermisse ich den satz noch sagen da wir
ja völlig fertig mit dem thema ich
vermisse den aufschrei der leute die
sich normalerweise sehr sensibel um
ungerechtigkeiten in der gesellschaft
kümmern die sich hier mal als geimpfte
öffentlich zu wort melden und sagen so
geht das nicht so kann man mit anderen
nicht umgehen ich bin geimpft und ich
sage so kann man mit denen nicht umgehen
also ich finde es auch sehr erschütternd
wie schnell man sich an ausgrenzung
mechanismen gewöhnt wenn sie eine
hinreichend große überschrift haben nun
also sagen kann es geht um die
sogenannte volksgesundheit den begriff
hat der montgomery jetzt wieder in die
debatte eingeführt der ärztefunktionär
wenn man im freien zweig einführt also
ich habe an einen traurigsten
weihnachtsmarkt von berlin endlich da
waren rechts drei stände links vier
stände es gab glühwein und zwei sorten
bratwurst aber man musste einen ausweis
zeigen und seinen impfpass um also im
freien umgeben von vier anderen leuten
seinen glühwein trinken zu können das
ist wirklich brutale ausgrenzung das tut
unserer gesellschaft nicht gut es fehlt
das gespür wie man umgeht mit dem freien
willen und es hat unvernünftig zu werden
dennoch finde ich den begriff der
apartheid einen ticken zu matsch muss
ich schon sagen dass ich war aufgabe als
journalist jahre geschah zuerst beziehen
ich habe sie nicht zu können sie machen
ich finde etwas unangebracht weil er im
historischen vergleich und damit auch
wiederum so eine art totschlagargument
in die debatte reinbringt ich bin dafür
dass wir die debatte öffnen dass wir
also nicht die ungeimpften ausgrenzen
dass wir allerdings auch nicht auf die
geimpften draufhauen und was ich eben
als besonders traurig finde dass man
sich sehr schnell daran gewöhnt dass er
zum beispiel dann erst bistum wie berlin
sagt zwei gottesdienste sei ja normal
sind ja normal das heißt es früher mal
dass die kindlein zu mir kommen oder
alle die ihr mühselig und beladen sein
kommt zu mir und heute muss eine fußnote
in die gerechte bibel aber wer ihr seid
nicht geimpfter müsst ihr draußen
bleiben das finde ich ganz ganz schlimm
das sind um christliche praxen solche
kirchen haben eigentlich namen kirche
nicht mehr verdient peter du hast ja
bestimmt eine andere meinung schätze ich
mal ich lese immer deine kommentare auch
im bild und ich schätze hier es seien
die blicken anderer mit dem begriff auch
so nicht mit ich weiß aber ich weiß aber
was er gemeint ist und ich verstehe auch
die überspitzung
und für mich als geimpften und wirklich
jemand der nicht selbst nicht große
bauchschmerzen vielleicht mit einer
impfpflicht hat geht der umgang und der
ton der angeschlagen wird eindeutig zu
weit und wenn und wenn es mal einzelne
supermärkte sind verdiente diskutieren
leuten das recht zu nehmen sich ihre
grundnahrungsmittel zu kaufen dann haben
wir in grenzen überschritten und der
kirche die aufgabe der kirche ist es
auch den ungeimpften die möglichkeit zu
geben zu gott zu beten oder an ritualen
teilzunehmen und dann mussten und ein
wirklicher christlicher pfarrer sag ich
jetzt einfach mal ganz frech als
agnostiker auch jetzt ist seine aufgabe
genau wie wie dem arzt man geht für sein
seelenheil in die kirche oder man macht
mal einen fehler gerade auf darf auch
keine untergrund immer er kann ja den
unterschied machen der priester unter
pastor dann muss er halt einen für
andere anbieten dann muss er halt gucken
mache ich einen mache ich einen einen
einen draußen aber jemand das recht
nehmen zu wollen zu seinem gott zu beten
oder an ritualen teilzunehmen
weihnachten das hochamt das größte das
fürchtet euch nicht alle würde man sich
wünschen dass ich da passieren auch
nicht so fürchtet ne also da strahlt die
kirche dann so jedenfalls nicht die
kirche aber zumindest dieses system
komplett dann die falsche botschaft aus
und mir ist auch wirklich wir sind ein
paar schritte zu weit gegangen in der
diskussion dann nehme ich auch viele
journalisten nicht aus man kann nicht
einfach
alle in einen topf werfen man kann nicht
links mit linksextrem immer in den topf
werfen rechts mit rechtsextrem und
ungeimpft mit querdenker oder mit
vollidiot oder darauf gesagt werden ja
das will doch eingesehen darf glaubt
soll das sagen kann er machen aber es
ist nicht gut der ist ja schön ist das
nicht und da müssen wir wirklich
wirklich gucken überschreiten der
grenzen auch ich werde wirklich
stocksauer wenn ich leute höre die
argumentieren warum sich nicht impfen
lassen und und warum sie irgendwie warum
sie einen wollen oder die maske zu
tragen und dann mit voller absicht hat
mich damals in einem voll mit einem halb
vollen flugzeug angesteckt also in
belgrad geflogen bin da hab ich schon
gefühl gehabt meine güte allem mit der
maske auf halb acht es gehört einfach
gegenseitiger respekt dazu derjenige der
sich nicht impfen lässt der muss der ist
eine persönliche bewusste entscheidung
der muss auch mit dem taifun von
konsequenzen dem aber die andere gruppe
muss aufpassen dass diese konsequenzen
nicht drakonisch sind daran gemessen
sind darüber dass noch eine frage
redezeit überschritten oder jährige
sitzt man sich mal was also bedingt was
mich ist diese runde ein bisschen
irritiert ist dass euch das überrascht
ich meine jetzt haben wir zwei jahr zwar
kein klassisches ding was abläuft jetzt
haben wir zwei jahre lang von oben panik
pur gehabt von den regierungen von den
medien die gesellschaft ist in einem
zustand der angst versetzt wurden und
wenn eine regierung mit panik arbeitet
dann produziert sie auch haus und
ressentiments und diese kosten diese
äußerung die meisten teilnehmer waren
umgelenkt auf irgendwelche nicht
komplett system ja mal ausreden lassen
ich hab's ja ausreden lassen dann wird
doch einfach ein haut ich bestätige das
was wir sagen dann wird haus produzierte
sich um eine minderheit austobt und das
ist eine wirklich gefährliches auch was
mich irritiert ist dass man die
regierung eigentlich durch kommen lässt
mit ihrer kommunikation ich beobachte
dass auch in der schweiz wo sind denn
eigentlich die fakten die fakten zum
beispiel eine zahl die nie kommt an
diesen medienkonferenzen in der schweiz
schwung das medianalter der an- oder mit
verstorbenen zwischen 83 und 89 jahren
die durchschnittliche lebenserwartung in
der schweiz ist 84 das heißt das sind
menschen die in einem betagten zustand
sind das ist der großteil der
verstorbenen sie sind alle 98 prozent
vorerkrankungen das heißt nicht dass man
dass das ist auch eine trockene wenn ein
80 jähriger steht vielleicht hätte der
noch länger leben können aber in der
führung in der gesundheitspolitik müssen
wir schwerpunkte bilden und man kann
nicht eine ganze gesellschaft in
geiselhaft nehmen wenn man bestimmte
risikogruppen hat die man schützen kann
die sich aber auch selber schützen
können und wir haben verlernt
auszusprechen dass der tod auch zum
leben gehört es darf dort niemand mehr
sterben es missionale gerettet werden
und der staub befähigt uns gesund super
ich möchte mal das ist die logische
folge diese panik stimmen die gar nicht
warum mir den kopf schütteln und
gesundheitsamt ein sohn weg so wichtig
die es mit beschäftigt warum dieses land
dazu schweigt
das niemand steht auf in keinem medien
ist ein kommentar schon so geht das
nicht mit den ungeimpften kann man so
nicht
geschrieben mit ja aber er gibt es ja
irgendwie eine sichtbare bewegung von
leuten außerhalb von von der
frage ist natürlich einfach dass genug
mehr kann man nicht als einzelner erste
aber gibt es hier eine anregung von
intellektuellen die sagen so könnte mit
dem oldtimer hier versuche es gab
versuche gab es anfangs auf hass hörten
einen nach den deckel bekam und
teilweise kann ich das etwas verstehen
was der geschätzte kollege aus der
schweizer sache ist total war teilweise
nicht alles wir haben natürlich auch
diese politik hier die in deutschland
mehrheitsfähig ist das muss man sagen
der schulz wurde für sein
unerschütterliches gewählt sondern
merkel wollte geschätzt für diese art
und weise wie sie die korona pandemie
angeblich gut ich finde schlecht
gemanagt hat das heißt der deutsche
sehnt sich nach jemandem der im wenn es
drauf ankommt sagt wo es langgeht und
der in dem er sich auch im zweifelsfall
verstecken kann also eine sehr mutige
oder im papa kann man sich verstecken
wir hatten mutti merkel ist haben wir
vielleicht onkel olaf muss einmal kommt
einem kopfschütteln groß reagieren
werden wie schon erwähnt und ich wehre
mich gegen die erzählung das von oben
herab etwas konstruiert wird und etwas
gibt geplant wird dafür kennen wir das
ja auch sachen einfach nur passieren
oder falsch laufen dass da vielleicht
auch die leute eine bestimmte gewöhnung
habe aber die erzählung von oben eine
macht würde etwas wurde etwas machen und
auf das volk hinunter gehen wir haben
den deutschen bundestag die sachen also
mitnichten ist
sehr gut nicht planen aber wir haben sie
zwei jahre lang das getriebene rhetorik
der regierenden und die aufgabe eine
führungsperson lass mich mal ausreden
die aufgabe einer führung besteht auch
darin manchmal die emotionen etwas ab zu
dem wir haben die regierung versorgt
also da die regierung der pauschal
freizusprechen die neue steuer kritisch